What we can see here, is that the debugger caught inside the plot-points
callback function, which gets called after our data gets loaded, that represents
our attendance data for all the games, and just as standard you check if we
use the console .table function, to display the first ten rows of our data set.
We can see here that it looks the same even though some of
the columns are smushed.
But we have a game ID, attendance, team one, team two,
goals, tie and so forth, so it appears that our data's loaded correctly.
Stepping once more through to the key function.
If we inspect what D is,
we can see here that it's game ID one represents the first game,
Italy versus the US and so forth with all the other data of our first row.
If we call the getUTCFullYear function on our date object,
we can see here that returns correctly 1934.
Stepping through to our roll up function,
we can see here [NOISE] that leaves represents an array.
And here we can see there is an array of 17 objects.
If we inspect each of these, we can see that it is one game, in this case,
from the tournament in 1934.
The second one is another game from the year 1934.
So what gets past the roll up,
is one group at a time of the grouping specified in the key function.
And it is the job of the roll up function to distill, in this case,
the 17 object or games into a single value, or a single aggregate.
Going back to our editor, to fix up our roll up aggregate function,
we need three things from each of these groups.
The first of which is the sum of all the games attendances for a given year,
the second is the longitude of where to draw the circle on our map,
and the third is the latitude of where to draw this.
To get the sum of the attendances, we'll be using the D3 sum method,
which takes both sum array or list-like object, in our case,
leaves, and an accessor function that defines what to actually sum.